bienvenue merci de nous rejoindre sur
TVfil 78 pour une nouvelle édition du 78
sport avec Anthony r bonsoir Anthony
bonsoir wilfri au menu de ce 78 sport du
football féminin vaincu cette saison les
joueus d'élancour ont été sacrés
championne de promotion de ligue ce
weekend à quatre journées de la fin du
championnat nous reviendrons sur ce
titre avec l' entraineur danig et sa
capitaine nous parlerons aussi du Athlon
après les trois titres historiques du
triathlon club de 50 ans Niel au
championnat de France jeune qui se sont
déroulé il y a 10 jours et puis comme
d'habitude en fin d'émission tous les
résultats du weekend alors on débute
forcément par le football avec cette
équipe d'ancour qui est un peu notre
parisgermain à nous exactement
exactement ils nous font d'ailleurs
l'amitié d'être ce soir parmi nous Dani
leggle et Kiny leggle respectivement
entraîneur et capitaine de l'équipe des
féminines de l'OSC bonsoir à vous
bonsoir alors un parcours presque sans
faute on peut dire presque un rythme
façon Paris sa-germain puisquà 4
journées de la fin du championnat et ben
vous êtesà ils sont déjà champions voilà
exactement déjà champion c'est quel est
le sentiment qui qui domine aujourd'hui
c'est la joie du titre la joie et
le le fait du travail accompli que on se
donne des moyens depuis 4 ans avec les
dirigeants les éducateurs et et les
joueuses plus aussi le club qui fait un
travail derrière le président qui nous
soutienne ça montre que le travail qu'on
a fait depuis 4 ans ça paye quoi donc on
va pas s'arrêter à là on va essayer de
d'aller beaucoup pour suivre l'aventure
exactement et cette aventure qui a bien
commencé du côté des joueuses j'imagine
que là il y a dû avoir une belle fête ce
weekend c'est ça on a fêté ça euh samedi
soir ouais tout ensemble et on s'est
bien amusé on a fêté ça c'était super
alors avant de de débriefer plus
longuement he ce ce ce titre ce ce très
beau titre de de championne de promotion
ligue je vous propose de de regarder le
récit de ce match he ce weekend donc
vous vous rencontriez le 7e l'entente
sportif du 16e qui est donc 7e au
classement qure victoires le titre était
àquis contrat rempli et de bien Bell man
récite ce match avec des images des
lodimine face à l'Entente Sportive du
16e les féminines des lancour doivent
attendre la fin de la première période
pour voir les filets trembler sur une
ouverture plein axe Miriam Sabi évite la
sortie de la gardienne parisienne et
marque dans le but
vide les Amazones passent une grande
partie de la rencontre dans le camp
adverse avec une possession de Balding
du FC Barcelone et un jeu très direct à
une ou de touches dans cette première
mi-temps les joueuses parisiennes ne
trouvent leur salut que sur coup de pied
arrêté à 45 minutes du titre les
joueuses de danilgle maintiennent la
pression et dès le retour des vestiaires
carolinets profite de ce ballon relâché
par la gardienne parisienne pour doubler
la
mise preuve de la domination des
Amazones dans ce second acte les
joueuses parisiennes se procurent une
seule et unique occasion bien trop peu
pour inquiéter l'OSC cette saison en
cours le danger vient aussi du banc sur
son premier ballon etodie Bro parachève
le succès 5quentinois de l'intérieur du
gauche la fin de match est une formalité
au coup de sifflé final les Amazones
peuvent exulter elles sont titrées 4
journées avant la fin du championnat et
accèdent à la Promotion d'Honneur
vraiment de la joie on s'est battu toute
une saison pour arriver là là c'était un
peu le match consécration donc on s'est
mis un peu de pression mais ça fait
vraiment plaisir c'est quoi la clé du
succès la clé du succès
c'est c'est énormément d'ativité de
concentration et de solidarité en fait
parce que c'est l'esprit d'équipe est
super
important alors pour ce match donc il y
avait valeur de titrre il y avait un
petit peu plus de pression chez les
joueuses Kini ou vous étiez vous étiez
plus concerné que d'habitude ça valait
la peine on a eu un peu plus de pression
même si on est très solidaire et que du
coup on a moins l'impression si on avait
été un club beaucoup moins avec une
cohésion de groupe beaucoup moins
importante mais ça valait vraiment la
peine parce que du coup on a on a
concrétisé une année de travail et
c'était super c'est plus difficile à
gérer une équipe de filles qu'une équipe
de garçons ça rien à voir c'est-à-dire
bien
ça ça rien à voir c'est en fait les je
dirais pour les filles c'est beaucoup
plus psychologique ce que vous allez
dire plus de diplomatie peut-être non
ouais ouais ouais voilà ouais il faut
prendre beaucoup plus de recul ne pas
parler sur le vavite faut et prendre son
temps et c'est un peu une deuxième vie
de couple voilà dans dans les vestiaires
mais c'est un pe c'est un peu l'atout de
Dan parce que il est un peu plus c'est
pas un simple le coach en fait j'ai fait
un autre club et c'était pas du tout la
même chose on parlait pas des mêmes
choses euh on peut être à l'entraînement
et parler de notre vie privée pendant 5
10 minutes s'il y a un problème il faut
qu'on en parle et c'est ça un peu
l'atout de je dirais même le gros atout
de de Dani on fait beaucoup de
discussion entre nous ouais on discute
avec les les joueuses B pas que sur leur
vie privée on discute aussi au niveau
football parce que je pense que c'est
bien de dire quand les choses ne vont
pas mais aussi quand ils vont bien parce
que ça ça motive aussi les filles de de
surpasser de de voir voir leur
progression parce que dans le football
féminin ce qui change par rapport aux
hommes c'est que les hommes en général
ils ont l'habitude de jouer au foot les
filles c'est pas tout à fait pareil donc
elles savent pas le degré de progression
qu'elles peuvent acquérir si elles l'ont
fait ou si elles l'ont pas fait donc
c'est bien aussi que nous en tant
qu'éducateur on soit là pour B pour leur
dire quoi et puis jusqu'à présent ça
leur réussi oui ça marche plutôt bien
tous ces outils ont fait que bah la la
mayonnaise a pris comme on dit et
justement cette domination se concrétise
au classement d'ailleurs je propose de
de jeter un il d'ailleurs parce qu'il
est juste incroyable en terme de points
puisque vous êtes invaincu he sur cette
saison aucune défaite même aucun match
nul voilà vous avez déjà 60 points et 10
points d'avance sur clamar et puis
derrière le 3ème Paris qui qui est à 43
points donc évidemment maintenant la la
montée complètement assuré et cette
cette différence de points est quand
même assez significative parce qu'on
dans beaucoup de championnats régionaux
il y a peu d'écarts dans les dans les
tri de tête c'est vrai mais c'est ça
aussi qui fait la différence dans le
football féminin parce que je pense que
avec la moi des des points qu'on a dans
un dans n'importe quel championnat
masculin on sera déjà champion bien
avant c'est là que vous pouvez voir la
différence de niveau qu'il y a chez les
féminines que chez chez les hommes et
puis les filles ont adhéré à votre à
votre discours aussi au final puisque ce
ce projet de jeu se met bien en place
comme on le voit là sur ce match il y a
vraiment un jeu direct très fluide pas
trop de alors je pas jeis pas le seul je
suis j'ai les mes éducateurs qui sont
avec moi en fait on on parle et on
pratique football ensemble donc on
essaie de de on va dire enfin nos idées
vont tous dans le même sens et on
s'entraine entre nous parce que je suis
pas sans défaut donc j'ai besoin aussi
d'avoir des avis de tout le monde et
heureusement que j'ai mes dirigeants et
mes éducateur avec moi et même des gens
du club on a cette année un directeur
technique qui nous donne un bon coup de
main on a les éducateurs des autres
sections masculines sur qui on
s'entraide donc je pense que cette année
et depuis 4 ans que j'ai commencé la
section féminine marche fonctionne bien
aussi parce que autour c'est structuré
c'est c'est tout le club et c'est la
Promotion d'Honneur donc qui se qui se
profile la saison prochaine tout
doucement on va pas on va pas sauter les
étapes il y a encore quelques matchs en
Promotion Ligue mais vous vous en sentez
capable justement de voilà de jouer à ce
niveau ah oui largement oui vous sentez
vos pasescendre voilà faut pas faire
l'ascenseur en fa bretonne qui jou dans
la plus haute
division
non bon après c'est à titre personnel je
pense qu'avec l'effectif que j'ai
actuellement avec deux trois renforts je
peux monter 2 ans de suite facilement
pour moi les joueux sont confiantes
aussi k sur on tou un petit doute mais
on fait confiance surtout au coach et on
en est sûr il continuera son son son
travail l'année prochaine et ça ça
devrait aller je pense et les joueus
vont rester au club il y aura pas de
départ d'envie de d'aller voir ailleurs
bah c'est possible c'est possible et on
commence à entendre parler de vous hein
quand même sur sur sur département pense
il peut avoir des filles qui qui qui
voudraient essayer plus haut c'està dire
vraiment de monter des échelons après
moi je serai toujours le premier à les
encourager parce que ça me ferait
plaisir qu'une de mes joueuses arrive à
à percer entre guillemets dans le
football féminin
maintenan moi le message que je voudrais
faire passer surtout des filles dans les
environ qui savent pas où jouer c'est
que le vrai projet sportif féminin il
est allé l' en coursilleurs c'est un
message pour le club de peut-être non
alors ce qui se passe à Montini moi ça
me désole un peu c'est j'ai rien de
personnel contre eux moi ça me c'est un
peu le problème qui se passe dans le
football féminin c'està-dire qu'il y a
des équipes qui qui qui's ont des
équipes en Lig qui arrivent pas à
structurer le reste de leur leurs équipe
moi je trouve ça malheureux ça c'est
c'est dommage pour eux quoi ça m'embête
plus qu'autre chose j'ai pas de mérite à
àc des jou à viennent chez moi j'aurais
préféré que leur jou reste et que
d'autres filles viennent chez moi et que
et que ça devienne un un un derby
pourquoi pas j'aurais préféré ce style
là que un club s'effondre et l'autre
mononde moi c'est comment vous expliquez
justement C ces projets bah qui qui
tombent à l'eau Versailles dans votre
dans votre poule notamment a fait
forfait cette année nanter dans dans les
haut scènes qui était dans votre poule a
aussi fait forfait il a il y a un vrai
problème de structuration des des projet
dans le FO fémin bah alors déjà je pense
que c'est vraiment il faut vraiment que
le club soit derrière parce que les
filles ils ont besoin de
sentir comment dire pas importantes mais
ils ont besoin de sentir épaulé c'està
dire soutenu dans ce qu'elles font parce
que souvent ce qui se passe dans les
clubs c'est que le football féminin il
est à part et le football masculin il
prime avant tout quoi donc c'est le
premier problème après il y a le
deuxième problème c'est les éducateurs
il y a beaucoup d'éducateurs et moi
c'est ça qui m'a donné l'envie de d'être
éducateur dans le football féminin c'est
qui pense que les sont pareils que les
mecs donc ils essayent de de bacler un
peu le travail pour essayer de faire
quelque chose dans le football féminin
alors que c'est pas du tout comme ça
qu'il faut raisonner moi la première
fois que bah d'ailleurs quand je suis
devenu entraîneur enfin la première
année que j'ai commencé je suis venu
c'est parce qu'en fait ma sœur jouait
d'ailleurs à Montini j'ai assisté à un
ces matchs et j'ai trouvais ça désolant
déjà le jeu qui qui pratiquait et je lui
ai dit attends une année de plus
laisse-moi monter un club à en cours et
tu V jouer chez N votre dernier objectif
pour cette saison c'est quand même de
rester invaincu en promotion de ligue
euh j'aimerais bien après là ce que
j'aimerais j'aimerais faire c'est parce
qu'en fait on a pas mal de filles et
l'année prochaine on espère pouvoir
monter une deuxième équipe à 11 parce
que là actuellement on a une équipe à 7
aussi qui est pas invaincu mais sur 10
journées à ne victoires et une défaite
je donc c'est déjà pas mal et j'aimerais
bien aussi leur donner leur chance en
équipe à 11 aussi pour qu'ell puisse se
préparer pour l'année prochaine quoi et
même à mes éducateur aussi leur donner
enfin leur donner la chance de pouvoir
coacher une équipe à 11 par que c'est
totalement différent qu'une équipe à 7
ant de de nous quitter Danis je voulais
vous montrer un petit message de
certaines joueuses qui nous ont qui nous
ont parlé ce weekend face caméra et
c'est pour vous directement regardez un
mot pour l'entraîneur bah félicitations
c'est vraiment il a travaillé aussi lui
toute l'année il est là tous les
entraînement il se donne à fond et il
nous enfin on le remercie il nous
remercie aussi merci beaucoup Danny
merci c'est clair net et précis merci
voilà le message est le même de votre
sœur
j'imagineoui merci à elle parce que je
pense que si elle serait pas assidu et
exemplaire comm elle le sont toutes et
ben moi tout seul je suis rien comme
elle je pense c'est pareil je pense que
c'est vraiment le groupe qui fait
actuellement ce qu'on est la réussite on
vous souhaite en tout cas d'être
invaincu jusqu'à la fin de la saison
pour ces quelques matchs qui restent
même si vous êtes déjà championne il va
falloir rester motivé encore un petit
peu de temps on parle de basket à
présent basket féminin aussi beaucoup de
sports féminins ouais tout à fait sous
weekend les féminines de l'Entente le
chîn et versaill débuté la phase de
play-off de National 2 en basket phase
finale qu' atteignne pour la 3e saison
sans avoir réussi à accrocher la montée
en National une auparavant avec elodim
moine et Julie Rocha soires nous avons
suivi au gymnase montboran ce match
aussi
décisif c'est l'objectif numéro 1 de
leur saison après avoir trôné en tête de
leur poule de National 2 de basketball
les joueuses de l'Entente le chîn et
Versailles jouent les play-offs
maintenant tout est remis à zéro et on
est bien placé pour commencer les
play-offs avec trois victoires et une
défaite mais maintenant on doit oublier
tout la première partie et se concentrer
prendre les matchs les uns après les
autres avant de rêver à la montée en
National une il fallait d'abord
s'imposer face à fu Deim le pivot
Virginie aincan soulage le gymnase
montboron et débloque le compteur sur la
première
possession les ivelinoises mènent
rapidement 177 et ne se laisseront
jamais reprendre porté par une salle
surchauffée à blanc je suis venu
encourager les filles le premier match
des play-off c'est le match le plus
important peut-être parce que c'est vrai
que c'est ça qui va déterminer si elles
gagnent ce soir elles ont toutes leurs
chance si elles perdent
risque d'être du après comme tout au
long de la saison régulière les
coéquipières de Chantal Descoins
s'appuie sur une défense solide couplé à
une adresse au shoot excellente il n'en
fallait pas plus pour que la messe soit
dite à la fin du 3è quartan 62 45 les
dernières minutes sont une formalité
score final 7256 avec cette victoire les
joueus de vinardic sont 2uxè à la
différence de points derrière sainte
saavine qu'elles rencontreront lors de
la prochaine journée le 27 avril pour ce
qui s'annonce comme le choc de de cette
poule de
play-off allez après les féminines on
s'intéresse au sport masculin à présent
ces dames ne nous en voudront pas on va
parler du triathlon club de
Saint-Quentin oui trois titres
historiques ont été ramenés des
Championnats de France Jeunes un titre
exactement un titre de champion de
France de titres de de vice champion de
France dans dans trois catégories
différentes par par club de Salin et
Jean-François r nous fait l'amitié de
d'être parmi nous ce soir Bonsoir à vous
bonsoir alors ces trois titres j'imagine
que le que le vice-président est est
satisfait non bah le vice-président
Satis il a le sourire en tout cas il a
beaucoup il a le sourire depuis depuis
tout à l'heure il a beaucoup le sourire
c'est vrai non non mais c'était un
weekend incroyable quand on on a
travaillé depuis si longtemps les gamins
on les a depuis qu'ils sont pupis ils
ont 8 10 ans maintenant ils en ont 18 14
16 ils sont au niveau ils sont au plus
haut niveau national pour nous c'est
c'est une grande récompense pour notre
école on se dit c'est formidable pour
nous pour tous les éducateurs tous ceux
qui qui travaille le coach sur des
épreuves on est déjà plusieurs on est au
moins quatre coachs donc c'est c'est
toujours une promotion c'est toujours
important de de pouvoir faire la
démonstration que ben on a une bonne
école et que ça fonctionne bien quoi et
puis vous venez par la même occasion le
seul club en France à avoir ce réaliser
cette perfance non réaliser cette
performance sur une seule épreuve on a
réussi à à mettre trois podiums dans
trois catégories différentes qui n'avait
jamais été fait avant et ça c'est
exceptionnel hein c'est pour nous c'est
c'est enthousiasment oui c'est sûr je
vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter vos
jeunes champions que justement hlo
dimine et Julie Rocha soires ont
rencontré ce
weekend j'étais vraiment content de la
course c'était une revanche contre
contre moi-même et les autres vraiment
beaucoup d'émotion à l'arrivée et même
après quelques jours après avant tout
c'est c'est une grande satisfaction ça
montre que le travail qu'on fait depuis
depuis quelques années avec le club et
aussi individuellement ça paye et puis
c'est c'est une grande satisfaction
c'est il aussi la joie et un bonheur
voilà un bonheur important alors ces
trois titres Alan Brachet donc qui qui
est champion de France chez les minimes
Aurélien GEM vice-champion et également
aussi thbao trembourg vice-champion de
France vous les sentiz venir C ces
podiums ou pas ou à l'entraînement il y
avait déjà des voilà des petits indices
qui vous disaient ah on va peut-être
faire quelque chose ils ont un potentiel
avant ils s'entraînent ils travaillent
beaucoup hein ils sont à 15 he par
semaine d'entraînement c'est énorme pour
des petits des petits jeunes comme ça on
on voit au travers de leurs résultats
qu'ils ont un potentiel après réaliser
sur une course mettre tout ça en
adéquation pour faire un résultat c'est
oui c'est la quintessence hein je pense
que quand on arrive à faire ça c'est
normal qu'il soit heureux he c'est c'est
très difficile à mettre en place à
réussir ils l'ont fait c'est bien bravo
on applaudit d demains surtout que dans
le duathlon comme dans le comme dans le
triathlon la tactique de course est très
très prépondérante et puis c'est c'est
souvent variable aussi he parce que le
jour J il peut se passer plein de choses
ah la course c'est la course on dit
partout avant un match on a on s'est
entraîné on est performant on sait qu'on
a un certain niveau après le la le
déroulement de la course fait que il
peut se passer plein de choses hein il y
a le vélo hein qui est qui est assez
compliqué parce que on court en Ploton
il peut tout peut se passer he chute par
exemple une chute tout est possible hein
il y en a eu hein on sait que c'est
compliqué il y a la chaleur il y a gérer
la chaleur il y a gérer l'hydratation
tout ça c'est compliqué pour des petits
jeunes comme ça de de d'arriver de de de
tout savoir gér en même temps bon ils
ont réussi à le faire c'est c'est
fantastique quoi et queles étaient les
consignes justement de tactique de
course que vous leur avez donné à Alan
Aurélien et et thibo partir doucement
essayer de se de se conserver pour le
vélo derrière bah disons qu'on avait
déjà sur la demi-finale sur le le
sélectif du alon qui avait lieu à
montlerry on avait on avait pas trop
parlé de de tactique de course on les
avait laissé faire gérit eux-mêmes leur
courses avec quelques quand même
quelques indications mais on voulait qu'
par expérience il se rend rend compte
qu'effectivement on a besoin d'avoir
quand même des coaches sur le bord pour
pour gérer une course tout seul c'est
compliqué ils sont encore jeunes ils ont
encore pas énormément d'expérience
encore thibo oui quand même thbao
commence à avoir d'expérience Aurélien
et et Alan un peu moins mais enfin ils
ont du talent ils ont vraiment du talent
donc ça compense quand même pas mal de
choses le talent ça permet justement de
faire des petites fautes il y en a eu
hein on en a parlé après on a débriefé
il y a eu des petites fautes mais
globalement le résultat est satisfaisant
c'est c'est fantastique quo c'est sûr
notamment sur cette préparation mentale
et justement cette préparation aussi
technique je vous propose d'écouter vos
jeunes protégés à qui on a posé la
question B j'étais l'un des favoris pas
pas forcément le premier favori mais
l'un d'entre eux et je pensais à la
victoire oui non je me sentais pas
favori je savais que j'avais mes chances
je partais comme un outsider et je me
suis préparé pour arriver sur le podium
et jeavais dans un coin de ma tête cette
place alors avec ces trois podiums on a
envie de viser plus haut encore pour ces
jeunes justement de les faire progresser
très vite vers l'élite l'équipe élite
qui qui est du côté de de 50 ansin ah
oui au niveau des structures on a essayé
de mettre en place justement pour que
ces jeunes puissent avoir une
perspective d'avenir dans le triathlon
on a une équipe élite qui court en D1
donc pour eux c'est un c'est un phare il
faut absolument atteindre cet objectif
et et on fait tout pour les préparer
pour arriver à intégrer cette équipe
élite oui c'est leur objectif de
triathlète ou ils ont une place à votre
avis en équipe vraiment nationale pour
défendre les couleurs français sur des
Jeux Olympiques par exemple ils peuvent
ramener des médailles aussi dans les
prochaines années pour l'instant au
niveau
potentiel le seul qui est encore qui a
la potentialité pour l'instant à son
niveau pour le faire c'est Alan on SAA
dans quelques années mais Alan c'est
vraiment il est junior à l'URE actuel
non alan est minimedon il est minime
donc il a encore vraiment le temps il a
vraiment le temps de progresser mais il
est vraiment c'est vraiment et vous y
pensez malgré tout aussi jeune vous vous
gardez en tête la possibilité de le voir
participer à des Olympiades par exemple
absolument ouis son parcours c'est lui
qui décidera he parce qu'après il y a le
parcours il y a les études il peut
arriver plein de choses en cours de
route mais pour l'instant sûr et puis la
vie professionnelle aussi les Ch bien
sûr c'est compliqué pour eux hein c'est
le triathlon c'est un sport il faut
beaucoup s'entraîner hein c'est très
compliqué de de de pouvoir même déjà
leur âge s'entraîner déjà minimum 15 he
par semaine c'est déjà assez compli avec
les études c'est vra qu' P vie
professionnelle aussi he parce que c'est
une carrière une vie une vie
professionnelle parallèle sportive en
tout cas assez courte parce que oui à un
moment donné ils ont des choix à faire
des choix entre le sport et et les
études on en perd pas mal pour les
études on trouve ça normal he que les
parents fassent des choix et queux aussi
fassent des choix on aime bien quand
c'est leur choix c'est important pour
eux on les soutient de toutes les
manières on est là pour les aider un
club c'est fait pour ça c'est fait pour
aider ses athlètes ou et donc c'est vrai
que pour eux après la vie
professionnelle elle est compliquée elle
est compliquée parce qu'il faut pouvoir
la construire tout en s'entraînant et en
ayant des potentialités donc on essaie
de leur faire intégrer des filières mais
des filières fédérales notamment des
filières fédérales notamment mais mais
il faut travailler donc ils travaillent
ils sont ils font ils font ça et à plus
plus court terme là les prochaines g
séances pour ces ces trois champions bah
on aura au mois de mai là ils vont
partir en stage pendant les vacances
parce que les vacances c'est fait pour
pour travailler hein pour eux donc ils
vont ils vont préparer ils vont préparer
le sélectif triathlon qui aura lieu au
Mureau dans le 78 pour après les
championnats de France qui auront lieu à
châteurou 1er juin donc là ce sera une
grosse échéance parce que le triathlon
on est quand même des triathlète à la
base très bien merci beaucoup
Jean-François d'être venu ce soir sur le
plateau de TVfil et puis on suivra de
près donc les les résultats de de ces
trois futurs champion en tout cas pas de
problème merci Merci à VOUS le 78 sport
c'est aussi l'essentiel des résultats du
weekend et c'est
maintenant Anthony oui en football il y
a eu peu de buts he ce weekend en
Division d'Honneur Versailles s'est
incliné à domicile face à l'Entente San
grincien un but à 0 il reste tout de
même 4e de leur Pol avec 51 points en
promotion d'honneur 18e journée 4e
défaite consécutive pour Guill encour le
SGC cette fois-ci incliné à domicile 1-0
face à l'Entente Sportive parisienne
dans la poule B trappe s'est imposée à
Saint-Leu sur le même score et retrouve
par la même occasion le podium du rugby
également et les phases finales qui se
poursuivent oui 32e de finale de
championnat de France fédéral 3 plaisir
recevait l'ogre rouan malgré un match
plein de courage les joueurs les joueurs
de Philippe Béard se sont inclinés 125
face à rouan et d'ailleurs tout est
encore impossible he pour le match
retour en facee finale régionale la
belle histoire continue pour embouiller
ils ont ils ont mis le carton du weekend
en infligeant un sévère 41 à0 à nemour
après avoir décroché la montée en
championnat de France la semaine
dernière ils sont donc qualifié pour la
finale d'Île-de-France qui aura lieu ce
weekend face à Sergy Pontoise et leur
équipe réserve brille tout autant
puisque ils se sont aussi qualifiés pour
la finale régionale face au chaînis il
brille un peu moins basket trappe qui
n'a plus son destin entre ses mains ouis
c'est de plus en plus compliqué hein
pour les traapistes en National 2 25e et
avantdernière journée en cas de victoire
trap pouvait assurer son maintien chez
le 8e calé malheureusement les traapis
se sont incliné 80 à 69 et dans le même
temps leur concurrent direct leement
s'est imposé à l'Orient du coup au
classement bah les cintinois n'ont plus
leur destin entre leurs mains il reste
13e et avant-dernier avec 33 points dans
cette poule de National 2 mais à un
point du M et dorme donc
mathématiquement tout est encore jouable
mais lors de la dernière journée les
trapistes doivent se s'imposer à
maobugge et en même temps ils devront
compter sur un Faua duent à Vitré et
dorment c'est difficile pour traap qui
s'imaginit jouer les premiers rôles et
pouvoir accéder à la division supérieure
c'est ces dernières années et qui fait
face à une réalité notamment financière
compliquée ces dirigeants nous l'avaient
expliqué d'ailleurs à plusieurs reprises
et effectivement ils étent un petit peu
démotivés pour cette fin de saison ce
qui explique ces mauvais résultats
mauvais résultats aussi pour le tennis
de table oui à à à toute proportion
garder hein puisque c'était la finale de
cette journée 7e journée de championnat
de France par équipe de Nationale 2
l'entente de voisins saint-arnou
s'incline logiquement he 10 matchs à 6
face au leader jouer les tours dans un
match qui avait des alures de finale je
le disais les joueuses de geoffrénisant
reste donc de peu he la montée en
National une de son côté encour
s'incline sèchement anime 10 matchin et
attend de connaître son sort quant au
maintien du roller roquet également ce
weekend oui 11e non roller roquet pardon
oui les chocs deslancour et ben ont
validé leurs billets pour les
demi-finales de play-off ils ont ils
étaient en déplacement du côté de
Besançon et du coup ils joueront les les
les demi-finale pardon 4 et 5 mai
prochain je vous ai effectivement un peu
perturbé sur ce cou ant c'était pour
voir si vous suiviez on va parler de
volet à présent le temps de remettre
toutes les fiches dans
l'ordre voilà exactement ou 11e journée
de barrages de régional une Montin
recevait véisi dans le derby de cette
poule pour les pour les playdown et les
joueurs d'abdellaatif nichi se sont
imposés 37 à0 2521 2521 et 2522 une
victoire qui leur permet d'assurer leur
maintien en régional une alors si j'ai
tout bien suivi on par on va parler foot
US à présent maintenant exactement voilà
6e journée de championnat franceélite ça
vous appréciez les Templiers ont chuté
pour la première fois de la saison sur
le terrain des moloses d' 20 point à 9
il reste tout de même un leader du
championnat et sur le terrain les
joueurs d'Emmanuel Charry ont connu leur
premier revers ce weekend mais elle elle
et bien ne connaissent pas la défaite je
veux bien sûr parler des cheer leaders
des Templiers les supportrices numéro 1
des élan courtois elles ont remporté ce
weekend le championnat régional des
cheers Cindy Lori Lesli et leurs
collègues ont reporté le prix de la
meilleure chorégraphie un petit lot de
consolation pour les Templiers il faudra
qu'il vienne sur le plateau pour la
faire la chorégraphie la prochaine fois
c'est et il nous reste très peu de temps
pour conclure cette édition du 78 sport
de derniè informations ultimate et juste
après extrem oui ultimate ce weekend
avait lieu le traditionnel zer P c'est
ce tournoi annuel d'Ultimate à plaisir
qui se déroule sur de jours une
compétition amicale où la crème de
l'Ultimate français s'est affrontée et
au final c'est l'équipe Sami Jérémy
originaire de carrière spissi qui s'est
imposé devant Versailles et les joueurs
oniens de l'équipe Scud et le prix du
fairplay a été attribué à synoptique de
Saint-Germain enle des noms tout à fait
particulier et escrime donc oui
escririme après avoir conquis une belle
médaille de bronze par équipe en Fleuré
au championnat d'Europe avec l'équipe de
France junior et bien la tireuse trapist
Jéromine et panjonga que nous avions
suivi en début de saison à récidivé au
championnat du monde en Croatie avec une
nouvelle médaille de bronze par équipe
voilà pas mal de bons résultats tout de
même m'adressé quelques défaites don
nous avons parlé dans cette édition du
78 sport on se retrouve lundi prochain
18h30 une nouvelle fois en direct oui
d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas à le commenter
ce 78 sport sur les réseaux sociaux et
Twitter avec le hashtag le 78 sport tout
attaché et nous donner tous les
résultats de vos clubs à lundi prochain
bonne
soirée